not gonna do the kabul trouble not i'm
gonna do it sorry i have i have no
travel to shuffle gang imma like I used
to be drunk now huh okay just living it
no first of all thank you guys so much
for coming out um it's amazing that new
duties which came out 1985 27 years
later we're still here we're watching it
on this beautiful in this beautiful
summer day in Los Angeles I'd also like
to thank the academy for setting this up
although I imaginary whoa whoa hello
reverb I'm angry because and we were
talking nay creek my girl talking we all
got tricked kind of coming into this I'm
not an actor anymore a lawyer um and I
don't you normally do stuff like this
but they send you this really nice
stationery and it on the letterhead
there's a big Oscar it says the Academy
invites you okay this is very good and
then when you open up your stationery
non-stationary it's the same Oscar and
it's like oh the Oscar you can't invite
you to come so we all thought you know
like we're getting a free Oscar or
something for showing up that they're
like hey nineteen eighty-five Best
Supporting Actor draft we're totally
overlooked here you go
feel free to write in because I got face
my desk at the office which should be
really dope to have the Oscar there they
don't but they do validate parking which
is nice so no Oscars but the you Holly
parking which is great um you know for
me I think a couple things why the
goonies holds up and you know what
people liking their kids like it is for
a couple reasons on the first is because
you know filmmaking is a team sport has
it amazing team members on the crew and
what the director Richard Donner did
which was kind of his through mind as a
director was a fancy word that they
would use which is rissa Milla tude
which is basically truth and dicks big
through line was taking people whether
it's in Superman or Goonies who are
regular people in really crazy
situations and what dick did is she loud
all of us to behave like kids would
normally behave in this crazy situation
talking over each other fighting with
each other you know getting freaked out
and he wanted us to behave like kids and
I think you know well some own surgeries
are variegated like Hawaiian shirt and
plaid pants that you're going to see me
wearing um I think the reason why it
holds up is because they cloud k CD case
I think that that's why it resonates so
thank you very much for coming out